[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that happened a few moments
ago
uh it's a wunderling versus azerbaijani
international master also women's
international master uh gunai mama jada
and it's uh quite an impressive game i i
knew that it was quite an impressive
game before i even checked out the moves
as i've received so many messages
already regarding this game
uh you've you can imagine from the
position on the thumbnail that it's
quite um
well quite a doozy so uh without further
ado let's check it out
and see what's happening so uh liam with
the white pieces opens with knight to f3
and the games are of rapid time format
so 10 minutes per player
now plus a five second seconds increment
not a lot of time
uh but you know that makes the games all
that more interesting as there's going
to be
you know a lot of a lot of craziness on
the board and it's uh from the
team from the polgar challenge
tournament where team polgar is facing
team kramnik
uh both of them having uh i think 10
very prospective young chess players and
they're you know uh battling it out so
here
uh liang is representing neem polgar and
majada is representing team kramnik so
let's see what happens we have d5 uh g3
preparing to vinca to the light squad
bishop so the king's indian attack
we have c6 and bishop gg bishop to g2 we
have bishop to g4
uh and here just castle so this is
nothing out of the ordinary knight to d7
and c4 now striking in the center uh
bishop captures
bishop captures in 95 and here uh the
position has been reached before but
it's
quite a nice one the bishop is under
attack also the c4 point is under attack
and some of the moves that were played
here are some like pawn captures on the
five queen to b3 the defending the
bishop putting pressure on b7
also just b3 is a known move preparing
to develop the the dark square bishop
however for this game
uh liang plays bishop back to g2 and
this is a straight out pawn sacrifice
the c4 pawn is now uh
free uh for grabs and uh
mama jada goes after it so knight
captures and c4 was played
and it is already sorry as of move uh
seven and bishop to g2 that we have a
completely new game
and a position that has never been
reached before so here at knight
captures on c4
uh straight up pawn sacrifice and d3 now
pushing the knight back
and now you have to decide you want to
go e5 do you want to go d61 or go b6
like i said it's a new position
so it's uh i would say it's very
unlikely that uh
that mama jada had this position on the
board at home like
ever uh but okay you never know knight
back to d6
and now the immediate e4 so white
already castle white has a nice fiance
with bishop the rook is ready to enter
the game
and black still has to decide what to do
with the king in the center of the board
so e6
we have knight to c3 and now knight the
e7
we have h4 if knight to g6 then you can
immediately kick it away with h5
so queen d7 uh probably preparing to
castle queen side and now
bishop to e3 uh we have d captures on e4
d
captures and knight to c4 now so the b2
pawn is under attack also there's
pressure on the bishop also
uh black is interested in trading queens
black is up a pawn so of course
it does make sense uh liam not
interested he plays queen to e2
and now comes knight captures an e3 so
eliminating
white's very strong dark square bishop
also uh
getting rid of white's bishop pair queen
captures on e3
and now remaneuvering this knight to b6
so knights the c8 uh the knight is
coming to b6 still
not um giving away any intentions of
where black will castle uh we have rook
8 to d1
queen to c7 and now queen to g5
making it problematic for um black to
develop the dark square bishop as the g7
pawn would fall
so h6 pushing the queen back queen to g4
and now only now knight to b6 so here
uh liam uh he he he has a very active
position but he doesn't have
much to show for it there's no clear way
of how to continue the game
and here he continues uh in the greatest
uh
possible way in the style of old masters
he plays e5
and this is uh another straight out pawn
sacrifice
so what can you play here i mean
obviously uh
best is to capture with the queen but
that's the problem of rapid time format
if you
you know just grab it and your king is
still in the center of the board how are
you castling
it's very very hard to make such a
decision but queen captures an e5 does
seem to be the the absolute best way
here and then if rook f2 e1
you can either move the queen right away
or even throw in h5 push back the queen
and then go queen c7
and even though you're uh you're better
now you're up to pawns
uh i mean it's a rapid it's a rapid game
uh it's not going to be easy where
you'll you'll have time to castle to
safety or
uh you know who knows what might happen
so instead after e5 we have
h5 first pushing back the queen queen to
g5 but now it's different now the e5
pawn is
uh defended so maybe a bit of a
different move order would have been
better
and there's a lot of pressure here so
you can imagine if you know
uh the queen moves and there was no rook
we would have a nice
a nice checkmate a nice opera house
checkmate if you will
so here knight to d7 putting pressure on
this uh
e5 pawn and now rook f2 e1 liang defends
it and now
g6 now preparing bishop to h6 this would
trap the queen
or rather maybe not trap the queen right
away but you would at least
win some material for example if a3
bishop h6 now
you would have to give up the rook
captures on d7 just to clear the f6
square for your queen but
it's also now a winning position for
black queen captures let's say queen f6
and castles
and this is now of course uh winning for
for black white it doesn't really have
any good compensation here
so instead after g6 we have queen back
to c1 by liam
and now finally black castles queen side
so
queen side castles uh and now the queen
back to f4 now going after the f7 pawn
and it's not all that easy for black to
make a move here for example
if you if you move the knight so the
queen protects the f7 pawn you can just
capture here with
check and now you can't really capture
with the king because queen f6 check
picks up the other rooks or you would
have to capture with the queen and then
you lose the f7 pawn
and now white is just better another
thing you could do is
defend with rook to h7 but it's a again
a very passive move to make for black
and uh it's hard to well it's hard to
depict how
you would continue the game whereas
white's plan is very simple b4b5 you
open up the
the king's position and you continue the
attack
okay so instead after queen to f4 we
have bishop to g7 now with a triple
attack here on the e5 pawn
uh and now uh liam grabs the f7 pawn we
have queen captures on f7
knight captures on e5 and now queen
captures on e6 first
with check king to b8 and now comes
knight to e4 so bringing more pieces
into the attack
uh knights the d3 now the knight is
nicely protected here attacking the rook
here attacking the b2 pawn
and here rook to e3 a nice rook lift
attacking the knight
and now uh black needs to decide what to
do here probably
the safest idea is to just go back with
knight to e5
but gunai wanted wanted more from the
position she decided to capture on b2
but this is just
extremely dangerous so now the d1 rook
is
attacked twice and also uh you could
trade rooks here if you wanted to
however
liang goes rogue back to b1 attacks the
knight here
rook to d1 check trading rooks we have
rook captures knight captures attacking
the rook on e3
and now there are a couple of good moves
here for for liam he could go rook to f3
with the idea of rook to f7
uh but if he did that we it's hard to
say if we would uh
well get so many requests to show this
game he played
rook to b3 and now you can see that a
lot of
action is happening on the queen side
here and the king is in a very
unfavorable position
there's a lot of pressure here on the c6
spawn and if
you know the knight moves you start
trading on c6
you will never be able to capture back
with this pawn so
black's next move is kind of obvious
king the a8
but this uh while this doesn't get out
of the way of the rook here
it creates more problems than it solves
here
knight to d6 now there's a problem the
b7 pawn is hanging so black needs to
defend it
rook the b8 was played and now the
problem is that
there's actually a forced checkmate in
10 moves here in this position
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this incredible incredible
sequence of moves while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on seeing
all of the lines and variations 10 moves
deep uh and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's of course rook captures on b7 and
this is uh
just uh that's just game there there's
no defending this whatever you do it's
just game over
uh point being that uh whatever you you
could even
give up the queen it would not help you
for example knight captures rook
captures and now it's just a very quick
check mate queen eight
check rook b8 and bishop captures and c6
checkmate
so obviously we're not going to give up
the queen and there's no reason to do
that but we just want to
explore our options so rook captures on
b7 was played
and now comes queen to e8 with check
so how do you defend obviously you could
defend with the rook or with the queen
if you defend with the rook rook to b8
then the problem is
bishop captures on c6 with check and you
don't really have a move here you have
to
either uh get get the queen here which
just runs into this checkmate the rook
is of course pinned it cannot move
uh and if you don't if you do something
else like
queen captures on c6 it's not much
better than just queen captures uh
with czech rogue b7 and queen captures
and b7 is checkmate
so after queen to e8 check we cannot
block with the rook we have to block
with the queen
obviously uh but now there's the problem
queen captures on c6 check and even
though
uh you give black a moment's breath it
doesn't really change anything because
here
again like i said everything loses a5
was played in the game
but even with the most stubborn defense
and i will show it as
you know uh it's uh it's a forced mate
in 10 if black plays the absolute
uh perfect defense uh but if not
then of course you can check made black
much faster uh i will show it as it's
very interesting knight to c3
you have to give up the the material
here uh rook knight captures rook on b7
knights the e2 with check king h2 and
now
knights to d4 attacking the queen here
so now uh you have to be very careful
uh but uh there's really not all that
much you can do just queen d7 now you're
threatening a lot of very very nasty
discoveries here
knight to f3 check this is the only move
that kind of prolongs the game
and now after bishop capture so we're
gonna have to give up a few more pieces
queen captures f captures a6
and now of course we run into checkmate
knight d6 check
king to b8 and of course queen capture
queen to b7 will be checkmate
so this is with the absolute most
stubborn defense uh which of course
never happens as there's no reason for
it to happen in the game
a5 was played but it doesn't really
change anything uh now comes
knight to c8 and that's just it now the
a7 square is nicely covered by the
knight
and we want to play queen to a6 with the
rook still unable to move
ever so black finds the only reasonable
uh
well move that prolongs the game bishop
to d4 preparing to shift the bishop back
to a7
but it doesn't help queen to a6 check we
have bishop to a7 and now
we reach the position from the thumbnail
or rather we need to make one more move
and that's knight to b6 checkmate and
everything is
uh it's been here everything is
completely paralyzed there nothing can
move
the king is in checkmate and this is
just uh this is just amazing when i saw
this position i was like
yeah i i wasn't planning on making more
videos today but i must make this one i
mean
it would simply be it would be a crime
against chestnut not to show such a such
an amazing position
uh so yeah of course the bishop cannot
capture it's pinned uh
it would be a check from the queen the
rook cannot capture anything as it's uh
pinned from from the bishop and well the
king is just in check that
and that's checkmate uh so after the end
the game was played out uh to the
absolute end which is uh something i
always enjoy and appreciate so
congratulations to both of them for
playing such a such an amazing game
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and again thank you so much
for her
suggesting me and finding such amazing
games i'm only one person i cannot cover
uh i cannot follow everything that
happens in the world so that's where you
guys come in thanks for that
i would like to thank austin wheeler
standish company llc
shira guzman uh happy birthday steve
kimmins and stephan arnold schelp
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day